good morning John so you know how I'm
not really a huge fan of like the
institution of advertising but then I
also built an entire business on
advertising revenue so that we can make
things like scishow and crash Buress and
all the other cool stuff that we do so
that was a weird decision for me it's
actually not because YouTube provides
two things that really nobody else does
one a truly massive audience that if you
create quality content and/or have a
strategy that matches well with what
YouTube once YouTube might push toward
your content and to a system to turn
those views into dollars real life money
so until there's somebody else who's
doing those two things better than
YouTube is no one will ever leave
YouTube like Facebook is just doing one
of those things and people are posting
their content they're like crazy YouTube
has been sharing revenue with content
creators for ten years during which time
Facebook has just been like so this has
created an amazing ecosystem of creative
people doing cool things on this
platform we can make money you know
maybe not a ton but without a lot of
headache you know here's the crazy thing
about YouTube advertising right every ad
that plays on a youtube video that
person is getting paid like ten times
less then if that ad played on TV and
for every minute of content watched
there's like five times
fewer ads so the average YouTube channel
gets like 50 times less revenue than the
average TV channel per minute of
viewership by why are my eyeballs worth
10 times more when I'm watching TV than
when I'm watching YouTube they're the
same eyeballs I promise there has to be
a point at which like your audience is
being valued so low by these people that
you're just like no he's the big secret
about YouTube ads they're YouTube's
whole business and it's a big business
it's billions of dollars but it's
precarious ads are just worth less on
the internet people don't like them
people skip them they block them to get
frustrated by them and while my eyeballs
for whatever reason it seemed to be
worth less on the internet my time is
worth more are busy this is not couch
time this is active time so this weird
situation is where we're at when a few
weeks ago some inflammatory articles are
posted about how major brands are being
advertised on top of very vile YouTube
videos a bunch of advertisers fearing
backlash remove their ads entirely from
YouTube and during this period every
youtuber saw a decrease in revenue also
Google's valuation dropped by like 750
million dollars in a day
no big it's fine our YouTube as a few
different systems that put content into
buckets they have a manual
that's like hand-picked channels like
crash course where they can say this is
good
advertisers it's safe go here it's very
expensive and then they have an
algorithmic bucket that's like no ads on
any of this stuff ever because it's
about marijuana smoking or whatever then
there's a middle area it's where it's
confusing and no one knows how it works
it up what we do know is after this
hullabaloo all of the algorithms got
tightened so while some channels have
rebounded a lot of channels went down
and then went down further as they were
put into buckets which weren't getting
as many abs this is really squeezed
creators who are making content that may
be good but not like super happy family
funtime stuff and again it's like is
this worth it is this relationship
between content and brands that was
designed by the way for radio is it a
useless holdover from another century
and if so are we gonna have to find
other ways to turn the value that we
create into value that we can spend and
if so will advertisers lose their
ability to reach people who are under
the age of 65 and if so is that really a
bad thing because do we really need
advertisers telling us how to spend our
money I think I feel like I could figure
that out of my own if we were forced to
if the value proposition breaks we will
find and we are at have already have
started to do this new ways to support
great content on the internet
subscription services like rooster
teeth's
first YouTube bread patreon really great
and productive relationships like
one-on-one relationships between
creators and brands that communities
like this continues to happen YouTube
and advertisers are gonna have to be
careful because eventually they're gonna
need our eyeballs more than we need
their pennies John I'll see you on
Tuesday if you are a creator who makes
stuff on the internet the internet
creators guild is a thing that is
designed to advocate for people like you
and if you're interested in finding out
more about that there's some links in
the description